Trump says John Kerry's efforts to try
to keep the u.s. in the Iran nuclear
deal might be illegal let's get more
from correspondent Richardson at the
State Department tonight the Secretary
of State is meeting with officials from
Iran Germany France and the European
Union to hold together the Iran nuclear
deal the problem for the Trump
administration that's former Secretary
of State John Kerry the White House is
dismissing Kerry's effort President
Trump tweeted quote the United States
does not need John Kerry's possibly
illegal shadow diplomacy on the very
badly negotiated Iran deal he was the
one that created this mess in the first
place I don't think that we would take
advice from somebody who created what
the president sees to be one of the
worst deals ever made I'm not sure why
we would start listening to him now a
source close to Kerry says the US should
be pushing for Iran to continue sticking
to its obligations under the deal and
there's nothing wrong with advocating
that in a statement the former secretary
spokesperson says quote secretary Kerry
stays in touch with his former
counterparts around the world just like
every previous Secretary of State like
America's closest allies he believes it
is important that the nuclear agreement
which took the world years to negotiate
remain effective his country's focus on
stability in the region one former
senator disagrees John Kerry is not
negotiating on behalf of the US
government I hope everybody he's talking
to knows said but in my opinion what
he's doing is inappropriate and he
shouldn't be doing it Republicans
complain of a double standard claiming
the criticism of John Kerry's light are
non-existent where many objected to then
eventual national security adviser
Michael Flynn as he discussed Russian
sanctions with Russian officials before
President Trump took office the Boston
Globe first reported Kerry's quiet
diplomacy for weeks the Europeans have
publicly lobbied the Trump
administration to stay in the deal the
United Kingdom's foreign secretary Boris
Johnson did so this morning visiting
Secretary of State Mike Pompeo as the
public lobbying campaign concludes less
than 24 hours before President Trump
announces his decision one European
diplomat says the chances the u.s. stays
in this deal are very small and that
it's pretty obvious that unless
something changes soon the president
will refuse to waive the sanctions that
keep the United States in the Iran deal
right Richardson lobs the state
department rich thanks what do you think
do you think former Secretary of State
John Kerry is breaking the law by
conducting the shadow diplomacy let me
know on Twitter at threat bear you can
use the hashtag special report or on
facebook at facebook.com slash Bret
Baier Sr